ولتوانيا واستونيا لدعم اوكرانيا
صور لاشتباكات بين القوات
الشيشانية وكتيبة ازوفي
الاوكرانية فيما البنتاجون ينفي
والناتو كاهداف عسكرية. السفارة
الامريكية في كييف تقول انه جرى
وجود اوكرانيا ويسعى لمحوها. قمة
استثنائية بين بولندا ولادفيا
عمدة بوتشا يعلن ارتفاع عدد
الجثث في المدينة الى اكثر من
العثور على مقبرة جماعية جديدة
في بوزوفا. جون كيلبي روسيا تعزز
وانقرة تقول انها ابلغت موسكو
بان الصفقة اكتملت قبل الحرب.
حقيقية اليها. البنتاجون يعلن عن
وصول دفعات جديدة من الصواريخ
والمسيارات الى اوكرانيا. موسكو
سنتعامل مع مساعدات واشنطن
قال زينيسكي انه لا يستطيع الجزم
ما اذا كانت القوات الروسية
وفنلندا الى الحلف اصبحت جدية
للغاية منذ الغزو الروسي. فهل
استحالة اجراء تحقيق كامل في
مدينة تضيق روسيا الخناق عليها.
مسؤولو الناتو لشبكة سي ان ان ان
المناقشات حول انضمام السويد
عسكرية اضافية لاوكرانيا بقيمة
ثمانمائة مليون دولار. قال
اراضي جمهورية روسيا الاتحادية.
قال ايجور كوناشينكوف ان الجيش
الطعام او الماء متهما موسكو
بعرقلة قوافل المساعدات. وعلى
يتجاهل الناتو تهديدات بوتين
ويضع الحرب العالمية على
الف شخص ما زالوا محاصرين داخل
المدينة دون اي وسيلة لجلب
عملياتها بينما الغرب والناتو
اصبحوا اكثر اتحادا بعد حرب
ينشر فيديو لقواته اثناء اسر
جنود اوكرانيين في موسكو تواصل
الرهائن الاجانب الذين كانوا
محتجزين. في المقابل وفي
روسيا تهدد باستهداف مراكز
القيادة في كييف ردا على ما
روسي حرر مدينة ماريبول بالكامل
من مسلحي كتيبة ازوف. وحرر جميع
الحرب? الاحداث والتطورات.
زالنسكي يتهم روسيا باستخدام
كييف والاشتباك بين وكييف كان
امرا لا مفر منه. وزير القوات
اسمتها محاولات اوكرانية لشن
هجمات تخريبية على اهداف في
وذلك للرد على اي استخدام لروسيا
للاسلحة الكيميائية في اوكرانيا.
روسيا ضد اوكرانيا فما الذي
سيحصل بعد تنامي وحدة الغرب يا
قنابل فسفورية في اوكرانيا.
بوتين النازية الجديدة نمت في
المسلحة البريطانية جميع
الخيارات مطروحة على الطاولة
الدعم البريطاني. في تطور لافت
اعلنت لندن امكانية ارسال صواريخ
نطلب من وسائل الاعلام سحب
التقارير الكاذبة على الفور.
الخوف الاسرائيلي. الشاباك اشتبه
باخفاء الصين جهاز تنصت في هدية
اربعمائة قال بايدن ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يرفض فكرة
احكام القوات الروسية السيطرة
على كامل مدينة الرئيس الشيشاني
شكوى للمسؤولين الاتراك حول
الطائرات المسيرة في اوكرانيا
مدينة قالت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
ان الفا وستة وعشرين عسكريا
وثلاثة وعشرين. تخصص بالذات لقوة
الفضاء الامريكية فهل نشهد حربا
الطرادة الصاروخية موسكو تعرضت
لاضرار بالغة بعد انفجار ذخيرة
قواتها في دومبس وتجري موسكو
تحويل جميع قواتها الى الشرق.
من امداد موارد الطاقة الى مناطق
اخرى من العالم حيث توجد حاجة
كوليبا محادثات السلام صعبة جدا
لكنها مستمرة. بوتين سنزيد ايضا
استخدمت اسلحة كيماوية في مدينة
ماريبول المحاصرة واشار الى
الابواب? البنتاجون واشنطن وافقت
على تزويد كييف بمروحيات قتالية.
مضادة للسفن قادرة على مهاجمة
السفن والبوارج الحربية الروسية
اوكرانيا قال فادين بويشنكو رئيس
بلدية ماريبول ان اكثر من مائة
الجانب الامريكي اعلنت ادارة
الرئيس بايدن عن تقديم مساعدات
تم اجلاء جميع طاقمها البالغ
خمسمائة فرد. بين تصريح كييف
ارسلت لوزيرة اسرائيلية.
الاشتباه برز بعد ان عثر الفحص
وتبلغ قيمة هذه المساعدات اكثر
من مائة وثلاثين مليون دولار ولا
يتفوق عليها في هذا الدعم سوى
الولايات المتحدة. اسلحة فتاكة
نبتون. ويبدو ان الطائرة بدون
طيار من طراز برقدار اثنين كانت
الروتيني للهدية على مواد مشبوهة
وتم تحويلها الى جهاز الشاباك
للاشتباه باحتوائها على جهاز
تنصت. الشاباك خلص بعد الى ان
وتشكيك موسكو هل سيكون هناك
تصعيد خطير بسبب هذه السفينة?
الكوب الحراري لم يكن يحتوي على
جهاز تنصت بينما ردت بكين بقولها
على متنها تم رصد مكالمات روسية
تفيد باصابة السفينة بصاروخ
كبيرة في ميزانية الدفاع
المقترحة للبنتاجون لعام الفين
بريطانية في طريقها للجيش
الاوكراني. فهل تقلب موازين
طوعا واستسلموا لكن المتحدث باسم
وزارة الدفاع الاوكرانية الكسندر
موسكو تقول ان اهم سفينة في
اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي وهي
التي تقصف المدن الاوكرانية
اضافة الى مدرعات وانظمة صواريخ
البحرية الاوكرانية في ماريوبول.
خسارة كبيرة. وزارة الدفاع في
الفضائية لجمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتية والمراقبة
والاستطلاع. وبسبب ذلك تقول
واشنطن انها ستضخ استثمارات
في الوقت تزيد فيه موسكو وبكين
من اسطوريهما من المركبات
اوكرانيا من فوج البحرية السادس
والثلاثين قاموا بتسليم اسلحتهم
محلقة للتصوير والمشغلة. لاحقا
اعترفت روسيا بغرق السفينة وانه
فضائية من نوع جديد بين
الامريكان والصين وروسيا? حال في
موتوسيانيك قال انه ليس لديه
معلومات عن استسلام لواء من مشاة
الامريكي جو بايدن معها لافتا
الى ان الاخير لم يظهر حتى الان
اردوجان فقال دول الغرب تسببت
بمفاقمة الازمة الروسية
يمكنها مهاجمة الاقمار الصناعية
الامريكية. ويأتي تصريح الوكالة
بوتين قال ان روسيا سترد في
الوقت المناسب بعد اعتقال حليفها
الامريكية عن محاولات متواصلة
للصين وروسيا لتطوير ونشر اسلحة
في كييف. تصعيد خطير. كشفت
استخبارات وزارة الدفاع
اوكرانيا زيلينسكي وصف بوتين
بانه الروحي لميدفيدشوك وعرض على
الروس تبادل الاسرى مقابل هذا
المعارض الاوكراني. في المقابل
اوكراني حليف مقرب من بوتين زعيم
منصة المعارضة من اجل الحياة في
الاوكرانية منتقدا على وجه
الخصوص طريقة تعاطي الرئيس
نهجا ايجابيا لخفض التوتر. اسر
الحليف. فيكتور ميدفيدشوك سياسي
المسائل خصوصا وزارة الخارجية
الامريكية. زينونسكي من جانبه
يرحب بتصريحات بايدن بانها كلمات
حقيقية لقائد حقيقي لان تسمية
بلاده باسلحة ثقيلة بشكل عاجل.
اما الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
الامور باسمائها هي امر اساسي
لمواجهة الشر مطالبا بتزويد
اوكرانيا. الكرملين يرفض تصريحات
بايدن اذ قالت ديمتري بيسكوف ردا
على سؤال حول هذه اوصي بعدم
التسليم بما يقوله احد في هذه
اوكرانيا ويقول الادلة تتراكم
على الامور المروعة التي فعلها
بايدن يجدد اتهامه لبوتين
بارتكاب ابادة جماعية في
المرة من جيرانها. واشنطن تزود
كييف باسلحة هجومية. زيلينسكي
الروس في اوكرانيا. وسنكتشف
المزيد والمزيد عن حجم الدمار في
سخيا لكييف. الدعم متواصل لا
ينقطع عن اوكرانيا ولكن هذه
خفيفة تربك جهاز الاسرائيلية
الشاباك. الناتو يقترب من اشعال
يشكك في استخدام روسيا كيماوية
بمدينة ماريو. سجال الاتهامات.
مراكز القيادة الاوكرانية
وبريطانيا تهدد روسيا وتقدم دعما
حرب عالمية بتجاهله تهديدات
موسكو. بوتين يهدد باستهداف
اوكرانيا والكرملين يرد على
التصريحات الامريكية. كييف تأسر
تنطلق في الفضاء. ما هي حقيقة
استسلام الف جندي اوكراني.
اوكرانيا تعلن استهداف اكبر
سفينة حربية روسية. وهداية صينية
حليف بوتين في اوكرانيا. الحرب
الفضائية بين الصين وامريكا
بايدن يقولها مرارا وتكرارا
روسيا ترتكب جرائم حرب في
ترى?